is outside the course in los angeles and
martha some breaking news in the last
few moments so we heard cheers from
britney's fans outside the course
[Applause]
yes some breaking news and a party very
much breaking out outside the stanley
moss courthouse in los angeles these
fans behind me many members of the free
britney movement who have fought so long
for their idol to be freed from the
conservatorship this extreme legal
arrangement that's been in place since
2008 which britney spears herself has
compared to slavery they've just been
told that that conservatorship has now
ended all parties were in agreement
there was no opposition the
conservatorship of britney spears estate
and so that's her money and her assets
and her person so her health and
well-being are no longer required the
free britney movement have their victory
because for all intents and purposes
britney spears is now free she will now
be in control of her near 60 million
dollar fortune she'll also be in control
of where she goes and what she does on a
day-to-day basis just to give you a
reminder for anyone who doesn't know
what a conservatorship is it's a ruling
made by a court over an individual who
is deemed to no longer be able to make
decisions for themselves britney spears
and her lawyers have long argued that
that conservatorship has been abused by
her father jamie who was the original
controller of the conservatorship and
others they say that not only was her
fortune out of her hands they also say
she was the subject
of her
bedroom being monitored and of her phone
conversations being monitored she is now
free and you can see
from the scenes behind me that there's
plenty of people delighted of the
court's decision here in los angeles